meet the micro to tesla's giga
tesla made a name for itself by going
giga taking over a big plant gm and
toyota used to run and constructing
battery factories so big referring to it
as just a factory wouldn't do
a rival a british electric vehicle
startup that went public a year ago is
placing its manufacturing bet on micro
it's constructing small plants in south
carolina and bistro a couple hours drive
northwest of london where it's
headquartered let's take a look
this is
a r d factory right now we're at
a really crucial time because we are
building our final stage prototypes for
our first two products the arrival van
that you can see just here and the
arrival bus just over there that we'll
go and have a look at
a rival's founder reckons the right
approach to building electric vans and
buses will be near the city centers that
use them in micro factories that can be
profitable at volumes in the thousands
instead of hundreds of thousands
it's planning to build these evs in a
modular almost lego-like manner with
extensive use of autonomous robots to
bring down costs
these are
the creatures that we are creating um to
handle uh the logistics anything that
moves on the shop floor of our micro
factory the the overall concept of the
micro factory is based on breaking
the the serial flow of the conveyor belt
which is the model that we've been using
uh for hundreds of years now using
lightweight composite materials for van
and bus body panels means a rival won't
have to invest in expensive metal
stamping or welding facilities or paint
shops so thermoplastics on their own are
great but actually and they don't have
the stiffness and strength of metal and
so that's where the composite part came
in so we started mixing reinforcing
fibres in with the thermoplastics in a
way that enhances their properties gives
us that additional stiffness and
strength that we need
arrival is one of dozens of companies in
and around the ev space that emerged in
the last couple years with special
purpose acquisition companies or spax to
raise money from investors and list
shares in the process
when a rival announced its plan to go
public in november 2020 it had a who's
who list of existing investors including
ups which had committed earlier that
year to purchasing 10 000 electric vans
arrival predicted its first product
would be in production by the end of
2021 on its first day as a public
company a rival was worth 13 and a half
billion dollars
that was as valuable as it's ever been
there wasn't an immediate crash but the
stock really started to go down in
november of last year
that's when a rival warns it will build
fewer vehicles than planned when
production starts in 2022
spending on tooling logistics and raw
materials will be higher than initially
envisioned
all of this means winning investor
confidence back will rest on the
shoulders of people like tom elvis
i won't steal frank's thunder too much
by talking about the bus but but a
little little preview a little sneak
preview yeah you know in a very similar
way to ride hail operators they've got
also a very bold
aspiration to go fully ev by
2035 that equates to
over 350 buses per year that need to be
upgraded the partners arrival has been
working with on its bus include first
group which operates across the uk and
ireland the plan is to put buses into
public road trials early this year
operating on real routes there's
something about a bus
uh horn that is different than just a
car
if executing on buses vans and
innovative manufacturing methods weren't
enough a rival has a project and works
for the other side of those milestones
in may of last year it announced a
partnership with uber to develop a car
purpose built for ride hailing
mike abelson the ceo of arrival
automotive knows all about getting
products from concept to production he
was vice president of ev infrastructure
and global strategy for general motors
at the tail end of his 35 years with the
company
just like starting any industrial
facility we're going to go through a
startup phase a ramp up phase
but we've done enough work and we've had
pull ahead versions of the equipment
already running so we've already had a
tech cell running for a number of months
you'll see that we've already had the
composite manufacturing process running
so we have confidence in the processes
we've done a lot of simulation
and you can see the hardware is going in
place now and between now and starter
production it's commissioning the
hardware and then starting to get into
the ramp towards starter production so
it's just fabulous to see it though
coming to life yeah yeah it's execution
time absolutely very exciting i'm craig
trudell and this is how we move
for more stories like this follow us on
your favorite platforms